I think it's fair to say that OverWatch
2 might be the most important game
release in Blizzard's history the
expectations are huge and there's an
entire Esports League again millions of
investment dollars riding on this game's
success now finally we can play the game
the multiplayer part at least and we've
got the change to 5v5 the new Heroes and
this new monetization model along with
the new mode which in my opinion might
be the best part of OverWatch too but
does this game do enough and why are
people so frustrated about the new model
that's what I'm here to talk about so
let's Dive In
[Music]
before we get into the video I just
wanted to remind you all to touch grass
and if that reminder seems pretty
important to you slap it on your body on
one of the score Esports new hoodies
yeah we've got a touch grass hoodie but
we've got a lot of other merch as well
that we think you'll enjoy I'll throw
the link in the description for you so
you can check it out for yourself and
again don't forget to touch some grass
so again to be clear the OverWatch 2
that released on October 4th is not the
full game I mean not really you might
remember the initial announcement of the
game nearly three years ago that said it
would be a standalone buy to play title
with a PVE mode it was also confirmed at
that time that if you owned OverWatch
one you could continue playing OverWatch
2 with all the heroes you already owned
but you wouldn't get new ones or the PVE
content that was slated to be released
with OverWatch 2. well since then things
have changed a bit sure you still have
all your old Heroes if you owned
OverWatch 1 which is great but now
OverWatch 2 is a free to play Battle
Pass based game that'll get PVE content
sometime in 2023. that delay is part of
the reason that it's so hard to gauge
OverWatch too I mean the PVE content was
touted as such a huge part of the game
initially but I'll talk about that in a
little bit the change to free to play on
the other hand brought with it a fair
amount of controversy for one if you
never owned the first game then you get
a modified new user experience in
OverWatch 2. bad experience slowly
unlocks the heroes and other features
and is supposed to help ease new players
into the game gradually not everybody
was happy about that though thankfully
if you're partied up with another player
the hero restrictions do go out the
window so you can play any of the
initial batch of Heroes although you
still can't queue for competitive you
have to unlock that on its own there was
also the insistence by blizzard that
players register a phone number to their
account in order to play OverWatch 2
which left prepaid phone customers by
the wayside it makes sense to persuade
players to treat others respectfully but
if the cost is leaving out a lot of
enthusiastic players I'm just not sure
that's worth it blizzard have since
taken steps to authorize accounts that
are older than a couple months without a
phone number but people are still going
to be left out here and obviously we
have a move away from a buy to play
model towards a free-to-play battle pass
at least for now I'm assuming that the
PVE content will be a separate purchase
or maybe drip fed to players it's not
entirely clear they just say 2023 so in
that way I guess it's similar but with
an added battle pass the battle Pass 2
is a source of frustration besides the
obvious fear of missing out elements of
any battle pass the heroes that get
released in the future will be part of
it and you'll need to unlock the battle
pass to actually play as those Heroes
now it is on the free track of the
battle pass and this battle pass allows
premium customers or people who owned
OverWatch one to Simply have kiriko the
new Hero at the outset but still it's
kind of frustrating compared to how
things used to be now from a purely
pragmatic standpoint I think free to
play kind of makes sense for OverWatch
too because they need to bring in new
players and retain them if they want the
game to succeed and an entry cost of
zero dollars makes that somewhat more
likely obviously
buy the game once I know crazy right
that's how things used to be you just
bought the game once but I'll have to
relegate that to the distant dreams of
my childhood along with Blockbuster
Video and Tearaway pants I guess and of
course if you've tried to play the game
in the last 48 hours you've almost
certainly run into a queue been
disconnected from the queue been
disconnected from the game after waiting
in the queue it's really not a good
situation sure blizzard has said that
they were ddosed but let's be honest
there are probably a lot of people
interested enough to try this game but
who aren't so excited about it that
they'll make the hours long pilgrimage
to the main menu we did get some quality
memes out of the deal though blizzard
really needs some good press and
logistically at least this launch so far
hasn't been that and as I said earlier
they need this game to succeed so does
it it's pretty hard to review a game
when it feels so much like its
predecessor but it's doubly so when a
huge portion of the development time
that we went into this title seemingly
isn't represented in the game that we're
playing right now when I say that I mean
that the more than three years of
development on OverWatch 2 didn't just
create the multiplayer we're now playing
a lot of work I assume was put in on PVE
aspects of the game that aren't even
playable yet okay but what about the
stuff we've actually got in front of us
right now the shift to 5v5 dropping a
tank from OverWatch 1 was maybe the most
worrying thing about this entire release
and while I do think there are a lot of
great aspects there are still some
things to work out the maps that are new
to OverWatch 2 feel as if they were
designed for 5v5 with only one tank on
each team you can't just stand behind
the rectangle man you have to find your
own cover a lot of the time and that's
built into the maps things are pretty
fluid and you can't rely on somebody to
just protect you now so things like
awareness flanking and peeling for
others just are more important the older
Maps though do still feel like they were
designed for two tanks like that choke
point on King's Row at the very
beginning it was a grinder in OverWatch
one but now it's like a shooting gallery
it feels like and too many of these old
Maps just kind of feel like long Lanes
with some limited flanking opportunities
and minimal cover which kind of clashes
with the new speed and fluidity of the
game while there's only one tank per
team now they honestly feel like they
pack the power of two into the one body
tanks feel more like mini bosses now
while they have mitigation active and
with the crowd control in this game
drastically toned down from the previous
one it's not even easy to stop them
temporarily tanks also feel like they
have a disproportionate amount of
influence on how your team actually
plays the objectives like if you have a
tank that's a Winston or a wrecking ball
and all they do is dive the enemy
backline you're on your own so you
better play like it having only one tank
puts supports in an interesting position
though sure you're still going to need
to heal the that one tank maybe more
than previously but theoretically you
should be able to find some more
opportunities to contribute damage too
overall I think the swap to 5e5 is
actually going to be really good for the
game but there are still some aspects of
map and hero design that could be
tweaked to make it even better speaking
of Heroes OverWatch 2 brings in three
new Heroes rebalances the old Heroes and
in addition to that some Heroes have
even swapped roles like doomfist
becoming a tank I didn't get to try the
new support hero kiriko too much but she
seems to put out quite a lot of
sustained healing while offering
accurate damage and defensive Mobility
junker Queen is an absolute force on the
front lines offering a flexible option
for absorbing and dishing out damage but
for me sojourn was the absolute
highlight of these new Heroes I'd always
wanted another hero like Soldier 76 but
one that offered some limited long range
options instead of utility sojourn's
combination rifle and railgun does
exactly that and her slide allows her to
get out of or into trouble quickly she's
not a true sniper but instead a capable
skirmisher that can pressure the back
line find new sight lines and Get Out
Alive
[Music]
plus she's Canadian I'm a bit biased I
can admit that I'm a bit less excited
about a lot of the reworks to existing
Heroes though sure Bastion is actually
fun to play now but while I understand
that they had to take the flashbang a
much-hated crowd control ability away
from newly renamed Cowboy Cassidy the
replacement ability that he got instead
is just boring and forgettable I get
that they can't give it the impact of
the flashbang I suppose that's the
reason the flashbang was removed but
something just feels like it's missing
I'd rather whip out a second gun for six
shots give my shots the ability to
Ricochet drop a smoke screen like
anything but the standard old rote I
Chuck a grenade still I think these new
character designs show that there's
plenty of milk left in the old design
cow but balance in my opinion is kind of
another story right now with one tank
per side and so much crowd control
removed from the game dive feels pretty
strong Winston does a lot of damage he's
hard kill he could get out quickly the
same goes for Genji who is not a tank
but is far more frustrating to play
against and frankly at this point I'm
sure people are playing a lot of things
because the game just came out they want
to try new stuff see what's cool but I
think in the short to long term this
could become an issue now is it slightly
better than in OverWatch 2 instead of
shooting two giant red energy Shields
I'm potentially only shooting one or
maybe even the tank themselves yeah it's
better I I confess it's better but if
those shots hitting the tank aren't
really doing much damage anyways which
kind of seems to be the case with the
New Balance changes
it's pretty similar in some ways too I'm
sure balance is as always a work in
progress but I want to move on and talk
about the new game mode in OverWatch 2
push which in my opinion is the best
thing they added to the game ever
actually maybe analogous in spirit to
Team Fortress 2's payload race push has
both teams fighting over a robot you get
control by being near it and then it
pushes this little barricade thing and
starts advancing it up the map your
progress is permanent but if your
opponents get control of the big guy
they're gonna push their own barricade
sort of like a tug of war these Maps
feel the most Like A Team Fortress 2
match that I've ever experienced in
OverWatch and I mean that as a positive
comment it's a good thing the spawns do
change as the barricade advances far
enough up the map that can be a little
disorienting but I think it's something
that players will adjust to but beyond
that I was impressed by how much this
new mode changes the flow of the game
sure you can still stack all your alts
to wipe out the enemy team and get
control of the robot but when you get
get to your barricade you still have to
successfully push it so you have to
think a little bit more carefully about
how to invest resources because it's not
just about winning one fight and getting
guaranteed progress on the objective
even if you win the fight and get
control of the robot you need to
maintain that control for a while since
your progress sticks and every yard
could matter the fights that keep
pushing feel worthwhile and exciting I'm
sure there are probably some issues that
I didn't discover or experience but for
me this is the real bright spot of
OverWatch 2. this is a great mode more
of this please okay so where does all of
this leave OverWatch 2 right now well
I'd say if there was nothing appealing
about OverWatch one to you that that's
probably still the case for OverWatch
too the formula is mostly intact if you
enjoy the game generally in the past but
got tired of shooting at Red rectangles
then I do think some positive changes
were made here and in any case it's free
so you can just give it a shot and if
you don't like it no harm no foul
assuming of course that you can actually
log into the game which I hope will be
improved as soon as possible what we've
got here though is still a shadow of the
game that was announced nearly three
years ago I love the new maps and the
new mode 5v5 ended up being a good
decision in my opinion and sojourn is
just so fun to play I love her but did
we need an entirely new game for those
things
I guess we won't get our answer until we
see what the actual PVE content is in
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this then hit the sub
button and ring the notification Bell
for Unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock
foreign